[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: I'm really
excited to host Sharon.
And she's going to
speak about her book
that comes out
officially June 7,
next week, called "Real Love."
And "Real Love" is
her 10th book, which
is quite a feat in itself.
So a couple of things about
Sharon before we get started.
Sharon is a longtime
meditator and practitioner
of mindfulness.
And Sharon is a leading
expert and renowned expert
in the field for being in a
mindful state, whether it's
leading meditational sits
or workshops or seminars.
I think she does
everything, pretty much.
So it's really exciting
to have her here today.
And I think with that,
I'll hand it over
to Sharon, who's going
to share about what
we're going to cover today.
And we'll take
questions at the end.
Thank you, and welcome Sharon.
SHARON SALZBERG: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
It's so lovely to be here again.
I was actually at Google once.
And Bill Duane was
introducing me.
And he said, Sharon is an OG.
So I said, what's that?
And he said, original gangster.
I said, oh, OK.
Referring to not
only my age, but that
I had gone to India kind
of early in that wave.
I went in 1970 and came back as
a meditation teacher in 1974.
So kind of preceded a
lot of current interest
in the popularization
of these qualities
and the methodologies of
meditation, mindfulness,
and now, increasingly,
loving-kindness and compassion,
which is really what
I've specialized in,
in a way, although I teach
a lot of mindfulness.
I don't know if I am mindful
all the time, as Rachel said,
but I do teach it a lot.
And sort of in that
evolution, my own evolution,
where I started out using
methods of meditation
to try to be more aware and
to understand myself more,
and really frankly, to be
a lot happier than I was.
I was 18 years old
when I went to India.
And I was a junior in college.
And I went through a
university program.
And that, of course, was why I
went, because I looked around
where I was going
to school and I just
didn't see the actual
how-to, the ways to meditate,
to bring it to life anywhere.
And it took that kind of
journey in those days.
So I've been really
interested just sort
of watching this wave
happen and realized,
you don't have to go anywhere
anymore if you don't want to.
And look at that.
What does that mean
for us here and now?
So I started with
mindfulness practice,
which was enormous for me.
And I also heard that there
were different techniques
available that would emphasize
qualities like loving-kindness
and compassion.
So loving-kindness is a
really odd term, I know.
And it it's not, generally
speaking, the kind of term
you hear people talking
about casually somewhere.
And that makes me
concerned that that
might make the quality
itself seem somewhat arcane
and removed from
day-to-day life.
Like, what is that?
Like something
quaint, something sort
of sanctimonious or
something like that.
But actually, it's meant
to be a live, vital sense
of connection, to
not feel so isolated,
not to isolate others,
to have a sense of being
a part of a greater whole.
As one friend of
mine quipped as we
were driving along somewhere,
caught in terrible traffic,
and they were complaining
bitterly about the traffic,
and the traffic was so
wretched and so terrible.
And then they paused and said,
I guess we're the traffic, too.
You know, what's it
like when we're not
considering ourselves separate
and apart in those ways?
Where the kind of constructs of
self and other and us and them,
where the great big other out
there are seen as constructs.
They may be useful.
They may be inappropriate
in certain situations.
But they're just constructs.
The reality is that we live
in an interconnected universe.
And here we are, right?
It's a world that's pointing
to that all of the time.
But our values, our
behavior, don't always
reflect that truth.
And so being able
to see more clearly,
to see more accurately,
to see the interconnected
nature of things is one
of the strongest ways
to leap into a sense
of loving-kindness,
just honoring that
state of connection.
Loving-kindness, or
love in this case,
since I'm now using
the word love,
doesn't mean you like everybody.
It actually doesn't even mean
you necessarily like anybody.
But we do understand
our lives have something
to do with one another.
It's a deep, deep
acknowledgement
that we do live in this kind
of world of connection--
in effect, that we
are all the traffic.
I have a friend,
Bob Thurman, who
is a professor of Buddhist
studies at Columbia University.
And he uses this image a lot--
which I actually, I think,
I use much more than he does--
where he says, imagine you're
on a subway and these martians
come, and they zap
the subway cars
so that those of
you who are there
are going to be
together forever.
He says, what do you do?
Like, if somebody is
hungry, you feed them.
If somebody's freaking out,
you try to calm them down,
not because you necessarily like
them or you approve of them,
but because you're going
to be together forever.
So guess what?
There's a lot of truth to that.
So this notion of
interconnection
isn't always like--
it's not sentimental.
It's not saccharin, sweet.
It's not even very
nice sometimes.
But it is that
fundamental recognition
that what happens over there
doesn't nicely stay over there.
It really ripples out over here.
And what we do, where we put
our energy, what we care about,
it matters because it's
going to ripple out
in just that same way.
And here we are in a world
where science is showing us this
and economics is
showing us this.
And certainly,
environmental consciousness
is showing us this.
Even epidemiology
Here we are.
And can our lives actually
reflect that truth
in deeper and deeper ways?
So sometimes when I tell
that story about Bob,
I go on to tell this story.
I was in New York City once,
sitting on an airplane, which--
trying to get to Tucson.
And the plane sat on the tarmac
for about 4 and 1/2 hours,
in what, looking
back, I sometimes
now call the breakdown
of civilization,
because it was getting
hotter and hotter
and people were getting
angrier and angrier
and screaming and yelling,
like, get me off this plane.
And I wasn't feeling
all that chiper myself.
You know, I was
sitting there thinking,
I'm paying rent
in New York City.
If they'd only let
me off the plane,
I could go home and
try again tomorrow.
At one point, the pilot sort of
took command of the aircraft.
He got on the PA
system and he said,
no one is getting
off this plane.
So I was sitting there
and not feeling very good.
And then all of a sudden,
that image of Bob's
that I had used so often in
teaching came up in my mind.
Like, imagine you're on a
subway and these martians
come, and they
zapped the subway car
so that those of
you who are there
are going to be
together forever.
And I looked around
the airplane,
and I thought, maybe
these are my people.
Here we are, maybe forever.
And I realized in that
moment a good deal of my ire
was this feeling of, like,
how long am I stuck with you?
And it's like, oh, forever.
Deal.
Right?
This is it.
How are we going to
deal with one another?
And that very much
is the sensibility
I bring into the practice of
loving-kindness meditation.
We can develop
deepened qualities
like compassion
and self-compassion
and understand them,
which is very important,
and really explore
those qualities
in lots of different ways.
Obviously, life lends us
a lot of opportunities
just every day.
Doing a simple
method of meditation
like putting your attention
on the feeling of the breath,
some object like that, and
having to continually return
your attention to
that object will
deepen the qualities of
loving-kindness and, first,
self-compassion,
which will blossom out
into compassion for others.
Because there's actually no
way to do it successfully
without that deepening.
Even if it's never
voiced, it's never
articulated, it's never named,
that's what we're actually
doing.
So I got to India.
And I first learned
meditation in the context
of an intensive 10-day retreat.
That's how I started.
And the first
instruction I was given
was, sit down and
feel your breath.
And first of all, I
was very disappointed.
I thought, feel my breath?
I came all the way to India.
You know, where's the magical,
esoteric, fantastic technique
that's going to
transform my whole life?
I thought, feel my breath?
I could've stayed home
to feel my breath.
And then I thought, eh,
how hard can this be?
It's going to be a snap.
Well, haha, it wasn't that easy.
I'd thought, OK,
what will it be?
Like 800 breaths, 900
breaths before my mind
starts to wander?
And to my astonishment, it was
like one breath or two breaths
and I would be gone.
And I'd be way gone.
And then comes the magic
moment where you think,
been some time since
I last felt a breath.
And I was told over and
over and over again,
but did not believe
that that was actually
the critical moment
in the whole process,
because that's the moment of
being able to be different.
Instead of judging yourself
and being harsh and feeling
like a failure and spending
the next four hours, say, just
in that rant about
yourself, thereby extending
the period of the
distraction and leaving
yourself exhausted
and demoralized,
we learn how to let go.
Just let go gently.
What one of my teachers
called exercising
the letting-go muscle.
And we learned how
to begin again.
Just let go and come back.
And that coming back is an
expression of self-compassion,
because the nearly
overwhelming temptation is just
to go on that rant, you know,
and to get lost in that.
And this is a chance
to be different,
which is a challenge, right?
The building block
of that difference
is some kindness
towards yourself.
And the reason I said it's
so important to understand it
is because that doesn't
mean being lazy or not
having standards of excellence
or not having an edge,
not having commitment.
It's actually a
pretty radical notion
of what is the best way to
succeed and make a change
and learn something new.
Because think of all that
time we spend in those rants,
and think of how
we feel at the end.
So that's why we
say that meditation
is a practice of resilience.
So that's a tremendous way,
whatever process we do,
of building that almost
unspoken but known sense
of loving-kindness.
We practice through insight,
through understanding,
through anything we do, anything
we perceive anew in a way
so that we see our
assumptions of aloneness
and a sense of isolation,
our assumptions
of fundamental difference
are really assumptions.
And we get to question them.
You know, is it so
that this person
at the other end of the world is
so very different, ultimately?
Is it?
Well, let's check it out.
We live in a time where
we can check it out.
And we can check it
out within as well--
the ways we categorize people,
the ways we dismiss people,
the ways we don't see people.
If you think about all the
people, perhaps in your life,
that you tend to look
through instead of look at.
The places where we
create an other, not
even just through
bias or prejudice,
but just indifference.
Like, who doesn't count?
Who doesn't matter?
And what happens when
you look more carefully?
That's all.
It's not trying to exist in,
awash with a certain feeling,
but just looking more carefully,
seeing things more as they are.
There's this tremendous
opening into that kind
of state of connection.
And there are ways of
actually stretching.
It's kind of practicing
in certain ways,
practicing paying
attention differently,
so that we are putting our
attention in a place where
these qualities of
connection can emerge.
The question comes up, you know,
what do we pay attention to?
If we're thinking
about ourselves,
are we singularly consumed with
just the mistakes we've made?
Or can we leave a little
room for a bigger picture?
Those mistakes may be true.
If you come to the
end of the day,
if you're almost
evaluating yourself,
yes, maybe you weren't perfect.
But what is the standard
of perfection anyway?
And what if we only
obsess about and are
consumed with and captivated
by those mistakes,
to the detriment of there
being a more truthful picture?
Can we give a little air
time to the other side?
Can we?
So what do we pay attention to?
And who do we pay attention to?
As I said before, who can
we look through rather than
look at?
And how do we pay attention?
How present are we?
How scattered are we?
How much are we looking
around the room,
seeing who might be more
interesting to talk to?
Who have we already decided,
oh, well, I heard about you,
you know?
You're like that.
No need to listen.
And if we see those things,
if we see those habits
or we see those
tendencies, we can actually
relax them or
relinquish them and be
there in a different
way, which is
the ground for a certain
sense of connection
that I'm calling
loving-kindness.
These days I call
it love, partly
because that's the book title.
But actually, people like Bob
Thurman, who is a scholar,
has said to me in the
past, loving-kindness
is so quirky a term.
Like, what does that mean?
You should just say love.
And so I'm experimenting,
clearly, with that.
Love is a complicated,
complicated term.
What do we mean by love?
Sometimes we really frankly
mean a medium of exchange.
I will love you as long
as you love me in return
and as long as you evidence
that in these 15 ways.
I will love myself as long
as I never make a mistake.
Well, what does
that mean really?
We know the fragility
of that state
and the breakability
of that state.
But really, we're
talking about something
that can be more
sustained or more renewed,
that can really support us.
When we talk about loving an
other, what does that mean?
In some ways, the
evolution of this book
actually is almost
entirely based on one line
from a movie, which the movie
is called "Dan In Real Life."
It's maybe now 13, 14 years
old, something like that.
My god-daughter was in
it, so I can kind of
place the movie by her.
She was really a very
little girl then,
and she just went to college.
So the line in the movie
is, "Love is not a feeling;
it's an ability."
Love is not a feeling;
it's an ability.
And this is very
resonant with what
we call loving-kindness or
even the state of compassion.
Of course, it is
a feeling as well,
and it's a feeling that in
terms of cultural pressure
and conditioning we yearn for,
we want, we identify with,
or the lack of with.
But think of it for a moment
as an ability instead.
It's a response
mechanism, right?
It's a way of being with.
It's a worldview.
It's a way of being present
with ourselves and with others.
It's a way of caring.
Like looking around that
subway and thinking,
we're going to be
together forever.
So it's a matter of inclusion
rather than exclusion.
It's seeing the assumptions
that come up in one's mind
and being willing
to question them.
Because in the end, it doesn't
make that much sense, really,
that we don't all
want to be happy,
that we don't want a sense of
belonging, things like that.
Love is an ability.
And I was very
captivated by that line,
"love is not a feeling;
it's an ability,"
in part because it did so
resonate with experiences
I had had doing
loving-kindness meditation.
So in addition to just
concentration techniques
like being with the breath and
kind of the stealth cultivation
of self-compassion and seeing
more clearly and having
more insight, there
are definitely
techniques that are
devoted to the deepening
of those qualities.
And I first did them
really intensively
when I was in Burma in 1985,
doing a three-month period
of practice.
And I had a very profound
experience when I was there.
And I think, like many
profound experiences,
it doesn't sound like
much in words, perhaps.
But it really
changed a lot for me.
And that was some sense
that prior to that moment,
I had thought of
love as a commodity,
very much like a package
in someone else's hands.
And it was in their power
to deliver it unto me
or to take it away from me.
And if someone took it
away from me, it was gone.
Every breath, there was,
like, no love in my life.
It was a little bit like the UPS
person standing on my doorstep,
looking at the address,
thinking, I don't think so,
and going the other way.
Whereas if I see love as an
ability, it's within me, right?
It's within my power.
And other people or
circumstances or art--
I mean, so many things
might enliven it
and awaken that capacity.
They might enrich it.
They might threaten it.
They might make it
very, very difficult.
But it's not in their
hands, ultimately.
It's in mine.
And that was hugely empowering.
Love is not a feeling;
it's an ability.
And that really is the thread
that runs throughout this work.
So the whole first
section of the book
is about love for oneself, not
in a narcissistic, egotistical
sense, of course--
which I think narcissism is
something very different.
And it's not about
being self-preoccupied
to the exclusion of others.
But it's about really seeing
ourselves differently.
I tell this story in there
about seeing a cartoon once
from the "Peanuts" comic strip.
And the two characters are
Lucy and Charlie Brown.
And Lucy says to Charlie Brown,
you know what your problem is?
The problem with you
is that you're you.
And in the second frame,
poor Charlie Brown
says, well, what in the
world can I do about that?
Then in the third
and final frame,
Lucy says, I don't pretend
to be able to give advice.
I merely point out the problem.
And somehow, whenever I
was walking by the desk
that this cartoon was
on, my eye would always
fall on that precise
line-- the problem
with you is that you're you.
It's like if you really knew
who you were, big problem.
Because that Lucy-dominant
voice had been so strong
in my earlier life.
And I will also say that
through particularly mindfulness
meditation tools,
I'd learned to have
a very different relationship
to Lucy, which was basically
seeing that voice,
hearing that message,
and being able to
respond with, hi, Lucy,
or chill out, Lucy, or have
a seat, have a cup of tea,
just relax.
Instead of like, oh my
god, Lucy's still here.
I've been meditating all these
years and Lucy's still here.
All that money in therapy,
and Lucy's still here.
What a terrible thing.
Or you're right, Lucy.
You're always right.
So that kind of creative
domain in between,
where we can respond
very, very differently,
is really-- that's the land
of mindfulness right there.
So how do we relate to
ourselves differently?
Having a sense almost of
a kind of innate dignity
that exists within
us, that we can
design our life
around and respond
to others in the same way.
And the second
section of the book
was really about
love for an other,
whether it's a
partner or a parent
or a child or a friend or
a colleague or whatever.
And when I was first kind
of researching the book,
I met with a lot of groups
and a lot of people.
I was really seeking stories
and people's experiences.
The first time I met with a
group, this man raised his hand
and he said, most people
think of a good relationship
as 50-50.
My dog and I were 100-100.
And I loved that.
And the real part comes in in
that the sense of generosity,
connection, caring is real.
It's not feigned.
It's not coerced.
It's not forced.
So here's a little section.
"For example, no matter
what we think we should do,
I don't think you
can coerce yourself
into loving your
neighbor or your boss
when you can't stand them.
But if you try to understand
your feelings of dislike
with mindfulness and
compassion, being
sure not to forget
self-compassion,
you create the
possibility for change.
Your neighbor or your boss may
still do things that annoy you,
but the anger and tightness
you feel in your chest
whenever you see them is bound
to diminish, leaving you freer
and more available for love."
This is basically
what we do, you know?
It's not to try to
pretend in any way-- well,
I'm sure this man really loved
his dog more than anything.
You know, it's not to enter a
state of hypocrisy or pretense,
or certainly not to try to
force yourself into anything,
but it's awakening to
different possibilities.
You know what it's like when
you're sure you know somebody,
and then you find out
something about them,
and it's like,
that's a surprise?
And the sense of almost like
awe that happens in that moment.
Like whoa, who
could have guessed?
I didn't know you did that,
or I didn't know whatever.
I also tell this story in
the book about assumptions
and how a friend of mine who's
a writer gave a talk somewhere.
And he, in the
context of the talk,
he spoke about Proust
and reading Proust
and "Remembrances
of Things Past,"
which had been a very
important book for him
when he was in college.
And afterwards he was
having dinner somewhere.
And this woman came up to
him and said, I have been--
I was at your talk.
And his heart sank
because he immediately
had a judgment about her.
He thought, well, she's
probably really poorly educated
and she doesn't look that smart.
And then she said
to him, the thing
is, I find reading Proust
in the original French much
more fulfilling.
And it was like, oh,
OK, there you go.
You know, so it's actually
a tremendous sense
of discovery and
exploration to experiment
with how we pay attention
so that we can actually open
and we can actually listen.
And then the whole third
section of the book
is about love for all beings
and love for life itself.
And this is really interesting.
In some ways it's
almost more interesting
these days than it has been.
It's very interesting,
and difficult, of course,
and demands a tremendous
amount of understanding.
Like, what do we mean?
Do we mean complacency?
Do we mean compliance?
Do we mean acquiescence?
Do we mean kind of liberated
understanding that's
not so afraid, that
isn't holding ourselves
or others in a kind of
prison of certainty?
What do we mean?
Because certainly, if it
means liking everybody,
that makes no sense.
In fact, the last
group that I did,
as I was trying to
collect people's stories
and things like that, somebody
said to me, in my life,
it was always said,
or it was just
the assumption that
loving somebody was
a supreme, rare, rarefied,
precious, unusual way
of relating, whereas
you liked everybody.
I mean, you just like people.
It's much lower.
And he said, you're
reversing it.
You're turning it around.
You're saying, yeah,
we can love everybody,
but liking somebody,
that's rare, perhaps.
I thought about it.
And I said, you're right, I am.
Because it's not love
in the sense of I
want to spend tremendous
time with you,
I want to spend
my life with you.
It's not romance.
It's not even saying, yeah,
let's go to the movies,
you know?
It's that fundamental sense
of acknowledging connection
and realizing we're
kind of all in this
together, like we're
all the traffic.
That's love as the way
I'm using the word.
And you may not like
somebody at all.
And you may decide,
you know what, it's not
in the sense of a balanced kind
of compassion including myself,
it's not in the cards
right now that we're going
to spend any time together.
That's just not right.
Or my best guess of the most
appropriate way, the most
skillful way to relate in this
moment is strong boundaries.
It's kind of a fierce message.
It's tough love.
There's all kinds
of possibilities
in terms of how we
actualize our relationship.
But that inner sense
of feeling, OK, we're
kind of all in this
together, what's it like?
What would it be like to be you?
To translate some
difficult actions
into actions that are produced
by pain, that cause more
pain and suffering, you know?
To really stretch, to examine
and be creative about the ways
that we relate.
Openness to the possibility
of loving everybody,
even if we don't like
everyone very much.
So I also tell this
story in the book
about once spending time with
this man named Myles Horton who
founded a school many years
ago called the Highlander Folk
School--
I think it still exists,
but it has a different name
now-- in Tennessee.
But it was like a training
school for the civil rights
movement in the US and the very
early environmental movement.
So we ended up-- he and I end
up spending a day together.
And I talked to him about
loving-kindness meditation.
And he sort of snorted at me.
And he said, oh, Marty--
Martin Luther King, Jr.--
Marty used to say
to me all the time,
you got to love everybody.
And I used to say, no, I don't.
I only have to love the people
that deserve to be loved.
And Marty would laugh
and say, no, you've
got to love everybody.
And prior to this book, I
so rarely told that story.
But I remember that
every time I told
the story, somebody
would come back at me
and say something like, look
what happened to him, you know?
He got assassinated.
As though it was the love
that weakened him, right?
And if he'd been vicious and
angry and hostile and hateful,
he would have been safe.
He wouldn't have been vulnerable
to anyone else's actions.
And I think that projection of
causality is very interesting.
Look at that.
So the fundamental question
is, what do we think love is?
And does it bring us down?
Does it make us stupid?
Does it make us sentimental?
Or can it be this
kind of clarifying
vision of, really, the
way the world actually is
and how we can respond to it?
So how about if we sit
together for a few minutes.
And then we'll just have
some time for questions.
So since I introduced it
as my first technique,
we can also go back there.
And I'd say, see if you
can settle your attention
on the feeling of
the breath, just
the normal, natural breath,
however it's appearing for you.
You don't have to try to
make it deeper or different.
And watch your
mind at the moment
that you realize you're thinking
about dinner or your vacation
or whatever it is.
See how you speak to yourself.
And if that is a
pretty harsh voice--
kind of punitive or belittling--
you can recognize that.
See if you can
soften that response.
Remember that our goal is to
just let go and begin again.
If you have to do that
billions of times,
that doesn't mean
you're doing it wrong.
You're doing fine.
OK, so you can
just find the place
where the breath is clearest
for you or strongest for you.
Maybe that's the nostrils,
or the chest, or the abdomen.
Bring your attention
there and just rest.
See if you can feel one breath.
Remember, the most
important moment
is the moment after
you've been distracted,
after you've been lost.
No matter how many times you may
have to let go and begin again,
it's not a problem.
That's the point, actually.
And I'll close with this
passage from the book.
"Today, with unprecedented
threats to our planet
and divisions among
people, awareness
of our interdependence
is no longer optional.
It's critical that we
widen our attention
to include those we encounter
as we go about our daily lives,
including our dry cleaner and
the stranger sitting next to us
on the subway.
"We extend our
sense of inclusion
even further to people we
may have disagreements with,
people whose actions
we disapprove of,
even those who may have harmed
us or those we care for.
We don't have to like
what they've done,
and we might take
very strong action
to try to prevent they're
doing it ever again.
But as our experiences of
the universality of suffering
grows, our sense
of interconnection
deepens, and we begin to
wish others could be free
in a new way, in spite
of their actions,
their beliefs, or their
positions in the world.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: And we'll open
it up to questions.
So does anyone in the
room want to start us off
with a question?
AUDIENCE: Oh, wow.
What is love?
SHARON SALZBERG:
You don't have to--
AUDIENCE: Well, no-- I
mean, my guess would be--
or my interpretation
might be like that kind
of unconditional acceptance
of self and other,
like you were suggesting.
Or compatible with
what you described.
I'm curious.
So you know, I think
about here at Google,
we have a kind of pragmatic kind
of problem-solving approach.
You know, when we see a problem,
when we see metrics at Search
or whatever, we
try to understand,
OK, this is what the problem--
here are the details
of the problem,
and then brainstorm
different possible solutions.
SHARON SALZBERG: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And so what I'm
hearing you say, you're
describing these kinds of
states or qualities of awareness
in terms of a kind
of acceptance,
a kind of interconnectedness.
And so these other kinds of
aspects to-- or qualities
of our experience.
And then you're also
distinguishing breathing
meditation as a technique
that guides us to that,
or loving-kindness meditation.
Do you see-- are
those like the only--
so this is what I'm
trying to tease apart.
It's like, are those
the only practices
that can guide us to
those kinds of states
of consciousness or awareness?
SHARON SALZBERG: No,
I think those are far,
far from the only practices
that guide us to that.
I mean, there are obviously
interactive practices, I mean.
You know, there's
that, as an example--
if you're talking about
reflection and meditation
and many others as well.
But you know, as part of
Search Inside Yourself,
it's just like me, which is that
intentional looking at someone
else and recognizing, oh,
that's a person just like me,
wants to be happy
just like me, who
has maybe backaches just like
me, or whatever it might be.
There are ways we learn to look
at one another differently.
Certainly, there are ways we
learn to listen, you know,
which are actual disciplines
in communication.
And there are many.
There's so many ways
of looking at what
may be a kind of manufactured
sense of limitation
and being able to dissolve that
into seeing things differently.
AUDIENCE: In terms of
separation or scarcity.
SHARON SALZBERG: Yeah.
Yeah, exactly.
AUDIENCE: So I'll ask
you to do a follow-up
question about that
of, how do you suggest
people choose or decide?
Or is it-- do you
just encourage--
do you encourage people to try
out the different techniques
or give other guidance for that?
SHARON SALZBERG: Yeah.
I mean, I think if
you're in a place,
as you are here,
where there actually
can be both a sense of community
exploration and guidance.
Because one of the great
hindrances people face
is their expectations.
And to have a voice,
however it comes,
to say, wait a minute, it's
OK that your mind wandered,
for example.
Which is one of the great
bugaboos of meditation practice
is people who feel utterly
aghast that their mind--
that they had a
thought, you know?
Because they think that's
not supposed to happen.
I failed.
I mean, countless
people say to me
if I'm introduced as
a meditation teacher,
oh, I tried that
once, I failed at it.
Well, what happened, actually?
You know, so I
believe in structure
and that kind of learning just
to have a sense of context.
Like, there's a
body of knowledge,
and you are in a place
where you can access
that body of knowledge here.
And that's all, you
know, is to have that.
And then the rest,
it's interesting.
It's like alchemy.
Something has-- we
have to do something.
It's not just fondly
thinking, these
are good values to live by or
sometimes-- it hasn't happened.
My book is actually not out yet.
It's coming out June 6.
So it hasn't happened
yet, but many times,
because of meditation
practices and techniques in all
of my books, people
say to me, I'm
buying your book for my cousin.
I could never do this, you
know, but they really need it.
You know, they're
so stressed out.
So what is that sense of
separation from actually
putting it into practice?
That's the hardest part is
saying, oh, it's a practice,
or it's a series of practices.
And that means application
and exploration.
And it means continuity,
because it's not always
going to be easy, you know?
So if you're willing to do that,
then I think it all happens.
AUDIENCE: My question is--
I'm a little reluctant to
say because it's not well
formulated in my head.
But I'm thinking about
parent and children.
I'm having a conversation
with my 23-year-old son today.
And I'm going to
stretch and have
a different kind of approach
after listening to you.
But thinking about
love in terms of--
the love as you're describing
is connection and not feeling
separate.
But in relationships,
particularly with parents
and children that--
how would you-- what would be
the proper way of describing
love where you are
acknowledge the separateness
that we are separate,
there are no expectations,
you're not mine?
SHARON SALZBERG:
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Well, I don't know that I
said or meant to say we're not
separate, we're not isolated.
You know, we're
not kind of bound
in this rigid
sense of exclusion.
But certainly, we're
separate, which
is why a true state of
love might sometimes
mean strong boundaries.
Or it might mean,
you know, no, I'm
not giving you any more money,
or no, you can't move in,
or whatever.
We're not going to
spend any time together.
Of course we're
separate in those ways.
And you're right.
It's a complicated, intricate,
amazing kind of relationship.
Well, also in that
first group that I
did where the man said he
and his dog were 100-100,
somebody was talking
about her relationship
with her son, who I think was
about the same age as your son.
And she said, I think your book
should be called "Real Love--
Simple, But Not Easy."
Because you know, it's not easy.
There's a certain-- it's like
a funny combination, I think,
of loving and
letting go, which is
the hallmark of a relationship
with an adult child.
And it's funny, I was doing a
Skype session with a friend.
I was on the east coast and
they were in California.
It was a friend's yoga
teacher training group.
And I was talking about
within the Buddhist tradition,
there's this term
called equanimity, which
doesn't mean indifference.
It doesn't mean
coldness or withdrawal.
It means balance.
And it's the balance
born of wisdom.
It's like perspective.
In any compassionate act,
or the examples often used
in that tradition of a
parent with an adult child,
you know, you love them,
you care about them,
you're on their side, you want
things to go well for them.
And you can't make their
decisions for them.
You can't say, well,
this is your livelihood
and this is your partner.
This is, you know,
your course of life.
Life is not like that.
And so it's not
apathy or rejection.
But it's a kind of understanding
that gives us a sense of space,
like being able to breathe.
So it's a combination of the
love and compassion, and also
that kind of openness.
So apparently there
were a lot of people
in this room in that yoga
teacher training program
who had young children.
And they were clamoring to say,
it's like that with young kids,
too.
You know, it's not just
when they're adults.
It's just like that.
You know, so it's
kind of an extension
of that understanding.
And you know, sometimes
we're on one side,
and sometimes we're
on the other side.
And it's just being
aware of that.
And learning how to communicate,
which is no easy feat anywhere.
How do you communicate
to a colleague?
How do you communicate to a
person you're supervising?
Clearly, you know, there
are some tools that
are kind of somewhat cliched,
maybe, your formulae,
but actually work.
Like, you know, if you're
supervising someone,
it's not that useful to
say, you're an idiot.
It's much more
useful to say, well,
when the memo six
weeks later, whatever.
Because "you're an idiot"
actually doesn't even
give that person the
information they need should
they want to change, right?
So we learn how to
communicate in a way that
is more expressive of, OK,
being on the same side,
wanting you to--
AUDIENCE: Respect.
SHARON SALZBERG: Yeah.
Yeah.
Simple, but not easy.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
Question over here?
AUDIENCE: Do you think
love or connection
can happen without empathy?
SHARON SALZBERG: Can it
happen without empathy?
AUDIENCE: Can you have
it without empathy?
It seems like empathy is
such a key part, which
is part of compassion.
But I didn't really hear
you use the word empathy.
SHARON SALZBERG: No, I didn't
use the word empathy at all.
I think empathy is in there
somewhere along the way,
for sure.
We would say that empathy is
like an essential building
block for, say, a
state of compassion.
But it's also not
considered sufficient
for a state of compassion.
Because as you may have a
kind of moment of empathy
towards someone's situation--
let's say they're having a
hard time and you sense that,
and you feel that, you
resonate with that.
You might genuinely have
that moment of empathy,
but then respond with fear.
Or with you're just
exhausted, and you think,
I'm so burnt out, I
can't possibly deal.
Or you might be
blaming, you know?
I gave you perfectly good
advice six months ago.
If you only listened,
you'd be better off.
Or in the state of
compassion, you know,
it also might get blurred with
that kind of savior mentality.
Like, I'm going to be the
one who's going to fix you.
Or we might respond with
compassion and loving-kindness.
So there are a lot
of elements in there,
but I think empathy
is essential.
AUDIENCE: OK, it sounds like
empathy isn't as sustaining.
Deeper is compassion.
SHARON SALZBERG: I think
it's different, you know?
So in psychological
research, they
say that we might--
the way they put
it is we might have
this state of empathy,
and we need this
state of empathy.
We do need it.
You're right.
But we might over-identify
with the other person.
So it's not like we're
looking at them thinking,
I can sense what it
might be like for you.
It's like we're there.
And then it's like we're going
down with the ship, you know?
So they say that empathy leads
to empathic distress, where
our own feeling of being
overwhelmed with negativity
is what's taken over.
So there's not
room for that kind
of generosity and stability
of the loving response.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Yeah, that makes sense.
Thank you.
One last question.
It sounds like you've
done vipassana meditation.
SHARON SALZBERG: Yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And you studied in Burma.
And is a lot of this book
based on the attributes
and the learnings of vipassana?
SHARON SALZBERG:
Well, vipassana--
I mean, it's kind of a
complicated question.
Vipassana's a term
in Pali, the language
of the original Buddhist text.
It means insight medi--
it means insight.
So vipassana meditation
is insight meditation.
And there are many, many,
many strands and techniques
and traditions and
lineages within that.
Goenka-- S.N. Goenka,
who was my first teacher,
was kind of an early
teacher in modern time
outside of Burma, which
was a very closed country.
When I first went to India, you
could go to Burma for 24 hours.
But he had left Burma,
and he was in India.
So he called his particular
style, his particular technique
vipassana.
So even-- it has a
much broader meaning,
but most people identify it with
that one way of practice, so.
And when I went to Burma, it
wasn't within his tradition.
I was studying with
other people by then.
But he was my first teacher,
so it was a hugely important
relationship.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
Well, first, my definition
of what is love,
I was thinking about that.
I was like, I'd say it's--
so I think what I'm thinking
is just self-acceptance
of all wholeness.
So like my dark
sides, my light sides,
everything from the past to
the present and what will be.
And that's-- and it isn't easy.
So that's my definition.
So my question is just
around the term love.
So you-- I liked what you
said about Bob Thurman.
And Bob Thurman is coming here,
by the way, on September 12.
SHARON SALZBERG: Oh, great.
AUDIENCE: In this room, I think.
Yeah.
So he's talking about his new
book called "Man of Peace,"
about the Dalai Lama.
So my question was
around the word,
because I think there's
a lot of triggers
with love and loving-kindness.
I like the abbreviation
of just using love.
I'm going to start
using that too.
But do you think it's overused?
Because--
SHARON SALZBERG: Love?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, the word
love, in terms of-- my thought
is it loses meaning over time,
like anything if you just
say it all the time.
So how do you know--
like, if I love you,
it's like-- is that the same?
Or can you share
more about that?
Because I'm always struggling--
I don't want to say love
unless it's really real.
But at the same time,
I want to express.
So what do I do?
Or what can we do?
SHARON SALZBERG: We can
call it real love, I guess.
AUDIENCE: I'll
just say real love.
SHARON SALZBERG: No,
it's very difficult.
Of course it's overused.
You know, I love my
manicure, I love my lamp,
I love my new car, sort of.
Not totally, but I
would have loved it more
if it was the other
color that I asked for,
but it was the second choice.
But I still love it.
You know, so of course we
use it in so many ways.
I think that in looking back
over my work in the world and--
now this is my 10th book--
I realized that something
that fascinates me
and that has moved me a lot has
actually been redeeming words,
that so many words
get kind of denigrated
or used in strange ways
or take on new meanings.
And I think we lose something
when we lose the word.
Like, I wrote a
book called "Faith."
So that was a challenge.
Even my friends were aghast.
You know, like, why are
you writing a book on that?
Because for so
many people, faith
had come to mean
being silenced and not
being able to ask questions and
not having a voice of your own.
And of course, it
didn't mean that to me.
And so I thought, OK, if we can
take back that word, we can--
perhaps if it's meaningful to
someone in a different way.
So I had a feeling I might be
doing something-- trying to do
something like that with love.
Because if we use it
in a certain way--
not like I love my new
car, but not totally
because it's the wrong color--
then I think we recapture the
power of that in that way.
AUDIENCE: When you
told the two stories--
one about traffic and the other
about being on the airplane--
what do you think--
what do you think
it takes to get
to where you have
those realizations
on throughout the day, right?
I know people use the
word triggered, which
I'm starting to find overused.
But you know, for you, or even--
for you, I'm curious, and then
also advice for other people,
right?
How do you remember everybody
else exists and the other is
not the other, and you know,
the situation is what it is.
I mean, what does
that-- how does that--
what do you think on that?
SHARON SALZBERG: I think
the meditation exercise
we did is like a fractal of the
whole path in that you won't
remember throughout the day,
but you can begin again.
Right?
And I was talking about words.
You know, like at the end of a
workshop, the end of a retreat,
the end of a program,
people often say, well,
how can I keep the level of
concentration I got here?
How can I maintain the level
of mindfulness I got here?
And my usual response is, you
won't, but you can start again,
you can start again
more gracefully,
you can start again with
less glue, you know?
With better humor, with more
kindness towards yourself.
You can start again sooner.
And that's what happens.
You know, of course we forget.
I mean, we're just human beings.
AUDIENCE: After
everything you've done
and as long as you've
done this, do you
feel some of that
comes naturally to you?
SHARON SALZBERG: Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
But that doesn't mean every
moment of the day, you know?
AUDIENCE: So assure us that
you have some bad moments.
SHARON SALZBERG: I have
some bad moments, thank you.
[LAUGHS] When I was,
a couple of trips
ago, leaving San
Francisco for New York,
my flight was 6
and 1/2 hours late.
And I was fine for the
first 5 and 1/2 hours.
I was like good humor,
sending loving-kindness
throughout the
airport, you know?
The whole thing.
At hour 5 and 1/2, I
started to lose it.
And just then, somebody
came up to me and said,
are you Sharon Salzberg?
I was so close to having a
temper tantrum on the ground,
you know?
SPEAKER: "You can start again"
is a great message, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Sharon
Salzberg [INAUDIBLE]..
SPEAKER: Thank you, Sharon.
Thank you so much.
SHARON SALZBERG: Thank you.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you for hosting me.